The task at hand was simply to remove the last element off the list and insert
it as the first one. Let's look at the code, the index of the last element is
the size minus one. That's the one that we remove. Now as it happens the remove
method returns the element that it was removed. Now you might say that's not
fair, how was I suppose to know that? So let's say that you didn't. In that
case, you could have done it in two steps. You could first get the element and
then remove it. Either way will work. Let me get back to my original way
because it's a bit shorter. Now that we've removed the last element we simply
stick it at the very beginning, like this. And there you have it, what was
previously the last element is now the initial one. Sara has a couple more
exercise prepared for you where you practice working with set, add and remove.
Have fun.